I have taught in colleges at various
times and over the 30 35 years whatever
it's been i've seen them go from
academic institutions to corporate
institutions and this is a very
dangerous thing academic institutions
used to be run according to the rules of
scholarship now they're being run
according to the rules of business their
marketing themselves to students their
packaging courses that are sexy because
students will sign up and pay a load of
money for them this is a dangerous trend
in an academic institution and it's
going not at every institution but
across the board you can see this in
almost any part of the country now and
that's just the institutions of higher
learning I think our different ways of
thinking can start very young I mean I
have a five-year-old and I'm teaching
him to be critical in his thinking at
that age he knows for example what
thermodynamics is and he knows that
everything you do produces entropy so
when you do something it's going to cost
you something and he's beginning to
understand that as a basic concept which
is one of the concepts that underlies my
arguments in the book which is you can't
get something for free if you're
believing that you're getting something
for free you're not really thinking it
through very clearly